this year's highest-paid tick-tockers
brought in more than 55 million dollars
in 2021. over the last year their
earnings have surged driven partly by
their efforts to expand their fame
beyond the platform that first turn them
into celebrities and this is serious
money we're talking up to five hundred
thousand dollars for a single post we've
got ivani gregg at number five becoming
tick-tock famous in 2019 as clown girl
posting makeup tutorials that same year
she quit her job as a lifeguard moved
from indiana to la and was one of the
original members of hype house a content
creator collective
her earnings 4.75 million dollars also
tied for number five is chris collins
collins is working as a hairdresser in
vancouver when kobet hit her brother
suggested she'd download tiktok while
she was out of work she did and soon
began amassing millions of followers on
the app where she played a number of
recurring characters many of them based
on family members her earnings 4.75
million dollars
we've got two tied at the number four
spot josh richards and bella porch each
with earnings of five million dollars
josh richards ticktock feed is full of
broly antics but brands like amazon and
cash app don't seem to mind that one bit
he's monetized his party animal persona
he co-hosts a bar stool sports podcast
has annie energy drinks and co-founded a
vc firm animal capital he's also done a
netflix movie under the stadium lights
and started his own production company
crosscheck studios a joint venture with
mark wahlberg's production outfit bella
porch is the third most followed person
becoming tick-tock famous in august of
2020 with this video
[Music]
which later became the most viewed tick
tock of the year born in the philippines
and later raised in texas she served in
the u.s navy as a helicopter mechanic
brands love her and in the past year
she's done sponsored content for google
prada and tinder
in may porch released her first single
build a it reached number 56 on
billboard's pop chart signaling what she
hopes is her next phase as a musician
number three is addison ray who started
making dancing tick-tocks as a student
at lsu
after seeing her popularity on the app
rise she moved to la to pursue being a
full-time celeb there she became friends
with a group of tick-tock stars and
helped form hype house a content creator
collective which elevated her profile
further she was seemingly everywhere in
2021 getting a lead role and he's all
that which briefly ranked number one in
78 countries after its august debut a
month later netflix announced a new deal
with rey for several more movies
she also has a lucrative sponsorship
with american eagle and her item beauty
line a joint venture with makeup startup
made by collective that sells its last
snack mascara and other products at
stores like sephora her earnings 8.5
million dollars
and the most famous siblings on the app
charlie and dixie de emilio
drawing plenty of comparisons to the
famous kardashian sisters they now have
their own hulu series the emilio show it
premiered in september and was renewed
for another season two months later in
december dixie performed at the garden
and nine other venues for the jingle
ball concert series alongside ed sheeran
and the jonas brothers and together the
sisters have a lucrative brand social
tourist a joint venture with hollister
sold at roughly 500 stores operated by
the retailer they of course take home
the number one and number two spots
charlie at 17.5 million dollars and
dixie at 10 million dollars
[Music]
you